[Música]
quero convidar vocês pra imaginar uma
história comigo uma história de um
menino que nasce algum tempo atrás na
periferia do rio de janeiro numa rua sem
calçamento em que o esgoto corre a céu
aberto numa rua em que a criminalidade
atingiu os níveis mais altos do rio de
janeiro em uma região do rio de janeiro
chamada baixada fluminense a maioria de
vocês já deve ter ouvido falar desse
menino cresce privado que muitas das
coisas que as pessoas de mais posse tem
acesso a esse menino cresce estudando em
escola pública esse menino cresce vendo
a dificuldade dos pais ao final de cada
mês para pagar as contas
vivendo de postergação de dívidas a
conseguir sobreviver
encontrando um meio como diga se de
passagem muitos e muitos brasileiros e
muitas e muitas brasileiras
e esse menino algum tempo depois
algumas décadas depois se forma em
harvard é um executivo de sucesso é um
empresário de sucesso dono sócio o
investidor de 13 empresas
eu gostaria que você imaginar sem comigo
o seguinte qual é a probabilidade de que
essa história seja verdadeira
muito bem quem acha que isso acontece a
toda hora levanta a mão pra mim por
favor na platéia
ninguém acha que isso acontece toda hora
quem acha que isso acontece com alguma
frequência levanta a mão pra mim na
platéia por favor quem acha que isso
acontece raramente
levanta a mão pra mim por favor de quem
acha que isso é praticamente impossível
levanta a mão pra mim por favor
eu tô aqui pra falar pra vocês sobre o
que move a mudança a história do menino
que eu contei para vocês é a minha
própria história
eu nasci na periferia do rio de janeiro
em maio de 1972 é vive a maior parte da
minha vida em condições bastante
difíceis
estudei a minha vida toda em escola
pública e num dado momento da minha vida
eu entendi que era hora de fazer uma
virada
e essa história que eu quero contar pra
vocês como aconteceu o que move a
mudança
em primeiro lugar eu queria muito eu me
lembro quando era pequeno quando estava
na época de entrar na faculdade e meu
pai sempre me disse o seguinte a única
maneira de você melhorar de vida é
estudando estude muito que tudo vai dar
certo e eu saindo de escola pública via
meus amigos sem fazer cursinho na
capital
eles também queriam passar no vestibular
mas tenho certeza que nenhum deles
queria mais que eu porque enquanto eu
fiquei estudando na escola pública em
jacarezinho uma pequena cidade do
interior do estado do paraná onde eu
morava
eles mandaram pra mim as apostilas do
cursinho que eles tinham acabado de
estudar e esse era o meu insumo para
conseguir estudar e para conseguir
chegar onde eu queria que era passar no
vestibular eu só tinha uma única
oportunidade eu podia fazer um único
vestibular em uma única escola pública
isso quer dizer que eu tinha vontade
eu tinha um plano eu sabia que para
vencer na vida tinha que seguir única e
exclusivamente aquilo que meu pai tinha
dito eu sabia que bastava eu estudar
muito e trabalhar muito e eu fiz todas
as escolhas na minha vida na direção de
fazer com que isso acontecesse de chegar
onde eu queria chegar que era encontrar
o caminho para sair daquela situação em
que eu me encontrava e é por isso que eu
repito tanto e com tanta freqüência
nascer com dificuldade seja ela qual for
não é destino é circunstância e é
possível encontrar caminhos para sair
desde que você tenha um plano e eu tinha
disposição e limitada em outras palavras
eu tinha atitude não adianta nada você
tem vontade não adianta nada você tem um
plano se você não fizer com que isso
terça se você não ousar sair da sua zona
de conforto para que você possa chegar
até onde você quer que aquele menino
pobre que nasceu na periferia do rio de
janeiro estudou a vida inteira em escola
pública quando chegou aos 40 anos de
idade
efetivamente venceu na vida
eu tinha um belo emprego eu era diretor
superintendente do sebrae aos 40 anos eu
tinha um bell salário tinha um carro com
motorista
eu tinha secretária eu tinha 250 pessoas
que trabalhavam comigo e eu não tinha
nenhuma das minhas necessidades que não
estivesse sendo atendida mas ao mesmo
tempo chegou um momento da minha vida
por volta dessa época em que eu me
sentia como esse bichinho que está na
tela atrás seja deve ter ouvido falar na
história do sapo que é jogado numa
panela de água quente a água vai
esquentando e ele se sente confortável
até que a água se torna quente demais
para que ele permaneça ali dentro
nesse momento eu decidi que era hora de
deixar o emprego em que eu estava
trabalhando porque eu senti uma
inquietude muito grande eu não sabia de
onde vinha essa inquietude eu sentia que
precisava transformar alguma coisa na
minha vida e eu aceitei uma oferta para
ser diretor presidente da empresa do
setor financeiro como vocês sabem
empresas do setor financeiro pagam
salários absolutamente enormes e 40 dias
depois que eu aceitei a oferta para ser
diretor presidente desta empresa
eu peço demissão e viro o brasileiro que
abriu mão do emprego de 900 mil reais
para empreender
depois de sair daquela situação ruim eu
consigo chegar no emprego dos meus
sonhos eu consigo ter um belo salário eu
consigo chegar no objetivo que eu tinha
que era afinal de contas venceu na vida
e eu resolvo pedir demissão do emprego
que me paga quase um milhão de reais por
ano e nesse momento eu era nada mais do
que um jovem de 40 anos pela primeira
vez desempregado
na minha vida eu me perguntava o que
será que aconteceu
por que será que eu cheguei a essa
situação pedindo demissão do emprego que
qualquer pessoa pediu a deus eu quando
contei o começo da história de que hoje
eu tenho sociedade em três empresas de
que hoje eu sou palestrante hoje eu fui
executivo por muito tempo não sou mais é
freqüentemente as pessoas dizem que puxa
que decisão corajosa isso aconteceu
quatro anos atrás pedir demissão do
emprego à la em jacarezinho na cidade em
que eu morei na minha adolescência
existe um ditado que dizia que as
pessoas só vêm as pinga que eu tomo e
não vêem os tombos que eu levo
quando conto essa história hoje já no
seu capítulo presente
as pessoas não sabem o que aconteceu
depois daquele lado daquela decisão de
pedir demissão do emprego de um milhão
de reais e de virar empreendedor
novamente do absoluto 0
eu passei os seis meses mais terríveis
da minha vida naquele momento porque eu
pedi demissão mais ou menos em julho de
e naquele momento meu pai coitado com 84
anos quase enfartou porque não consegui
entender o que eu tinha na cabeça como é
que alguém que conseguiu tudo na vida
vindo do zero vindo do absolutamente
precário resolve tomar uma decisão dessa
de pedir demissão de querer virar
empreendedor os 40 anos e até aquele
momento também não tinha muita certeza
daquilo que eu estava fazendo também não
tinha muita clareza quanto às escolhas
que estava fazendo só sabia que eu
precisava mudar alguma coisa na minha
vida e isso acontece por uma razão muito
clara
eu disse para vocês que muito jovem eu
decidi que ia mudar de vida
eu decidi que eu ia vencer na vida e
vencer na vida para mim significa uma
única coisa o dinheiro eu diria o meu
sucesso baseado na quantidade de
dinheiro que eu tivesse na minha conta
bancária e no momento em que eu tenho
mais dinheiro na minha conta bancária é
exatamente o mesmo momento em que eu me
sinto mais infeliz e é por isso que eu
pedi demissão mas entre o ato de tomar a
demissão de pedir demissão e o que
aconteceu ao longo desses quatro anos eu
passei seis meses muito difíceis
em dezembro de 2013 no meio de toda essa
confusão eu resolvi sumir de tudo eu
resolvi pegar um vôo eu podia pegar esse
vôo mas isso é relevante não precisava
pegar um vôo para fazer isso mas eu
resolvi pegar um vôo e resolvi ir para o
nepal e lá no nepal eu descobrir aquilo
que faltava para mim o que faltava pra
mim ao longo de toda essa caminhada de
20 anos em que me tornei um executivo de
sucesso em que me tornei um executivo
com um salário de 1 milhão de reais
a propósito o propósito é a razão pela
qual cada um de nós faz aquilo que faz
se eu perguntar pra você agora o quê
porque você faz aquilo que você faz por
que você sai da cama todos os dias de
manhã o triste dessa pergunta que a
maioria das pessoas responde dizendo que
sai da cama todos os dias de manhã única
e exclusivamente para trabalhar trocando
tempo por dinheiro porque precisam de um
salário no final do mesmo
essa é uma das coisas mais tristes que
um ser humano pode fazer com a própria
vida porque o propósito é o que move a
humanidade propósito é o que move as
pessoas propósito é aquilo que coloca
brilho nos olhos das pessoas
outro dia eu conversava com um grupo de
vendedores em curitiba que vende um
jóias e eu perguntamos por que saem da
cama de manhã a resposta delas foi a
seguinte nós saímos da cama para vender
jóias
eu queria tudo que eu queria naquele
momento ela tem uma campanha daquelas
bem grande que você aperta e faz um
barulho estridente toca uma sirene pé
porque a resposta também errada
pensem comigo porque uma mulher comprou
uma jóia seja ela qual for
uma mulher com uma jóia para ser mais
feliz mais bonita mais desejada porque
um homem comprou uma jóia um homem
comprou uma jóia para fazer a mulher que
ele ama mais feliz portanto uma
vendedora de jóias têm um propósito
muito maior naquilo que faz e eu queria
ter propósito naquilo que eu fazia
o propósito é o que está nesse slide e é
por isso que hoje eu faço aquilo que
faço
semana passada tive um evento com mais
ou menos 500 jovens fazendo uma palestra
parecida com essa que estou fazendo
neste momento
5 no dia seguinte recebi essa mensagem
da organização do evento
até hoje tenho clareza muito grande a
respeito de que aquilo que eu nasci pra
fazer é espalhar mensagens que de alguma
maneira ajude as pessoas quando isso
acontece eu sinto que estou caminhando
para construir aquilo que eu chamo
delegado
mas para que isso aconteça a gente
precisa fazer o que eu chamo de desligar
o piloto automático
vários palestrantes na tarde de hoje
falaram sobre o nosso estado acelerado
em função do momento que vivemos no
mundo em função da aceleração
tecnológica em função de tudo que nos
cerca e eu queria fazer um convite pra
vocês ouçam por 10 segundos com atenção
o silêncio incomoda sabem por quê porque
a gente raramente ouvir o som do
silêncio ea única forma de nós entramos
em contato com aquilo que de mais
relevante
nós temos em termos de missão na vida é
nos oportunizando nesses momentos de
parada para pensar a respeito daquilo
que queremos e daquilo que temos de
prioridades aquilo que nos faz humanos
em última instância é aquilo que eu
chamo de escolhas conscientes
o problema de viver em permanente estado
de piloto automático é que nós não
fazemos escolhas conscientes nós sejamos
uma espécie de síndrome de zeca
pagodinho já ouviram falar
deixa a vida me levar vida leva eu eu
vou vivendo um dia depois do outro sem
parar pra pensar pra questionar qual é o
meu papel porque é que eu estou aqui eu
passei 20 anos da minha vida
profissional fazendo isso correndo atrás
de dinheiro até chegar um dia em que no
alto da montanha no nepal no himalaia
eu me deparei com o seguinte raciocínio
tem um filho lucas de 15 anos que na
época tinha 12
naquela época o nunca era enlouquecido
para brincar com lego aqueles brinquedos
de montar que muitos de vocês já ouviram
falar nunca quando hoje ele não brinca
mais ele está com 15 anos mas até hoje
ele tem guardados os legos dele quando
você abre a porta do armário do lucca em
lego de tudo que é jeito que você possa
imaginar lá dentro
o lado triste disso é que preencher
aquele armário do lucca de lego que é
algo que nunca na vida dele ele me pediu
para fazer naquela busca enlouquecida
pelo sucesso que para mim era apenas
dinheiro
eu joguei fora muito
a única coisa que até hoje em algum
momento da vida do lucca ele já me
cobrou e nem que eu ganhe todo o
dinheiro do mundo eu compro esse tempo
de volta é por isso que a gente precisa
se permite parar pra pensar em parar
para olhar para a própria vida e parar
pra pensar nas escolhas que nós estamos
fazendo porque quando nós olhamos para
as escolhas que fazemos atrás de
propósito
nas nossas vidas a gente caminha a
passos largos na direção de fazer o que
eu chamo de construir um legado a gente
acha que é legal
tem a ver com grandeza não tem a ver com
grandeza daquilo que se faz lá fora com
a construção de um teatro de uma ponte
ou seja lá o que for
legado é a possibilidade que nós temos
todos os dias de fazer a diferença na
vida de alguém legado é a diferença que
nós fazemos a cada instante na vida das
pessoas que estão à nossa volta
ao sair por aquela porta hoje no final
desse evento se os 15 minutos que passei
com vocês deixarem alguma coisa que seja
útil eu sei que estou caminhando na
direção da construção do meu legado e aí
para a gente encerrar eu quero
acrescentar uma coisa a mais
naquela equação a respeito do que move a
mudança
nós falamos que o que move a mudança é
vontade estratégia e atitude mas
principalmente aquilo que move a mudança
é ter um porquê maior que eu
quando eu olho apenas pra mim eu limito
me a possibilidade de mudar o que quer
que seja porque a mudança de verdade
acontece quando nós olhamos para o outro
e é isso nós voltarmos naquela história
do início e se eu perguntar pra vocês
imaginarem uma história que tenha vocês
como personagens principais e perguntar
se é possível mudar o que quer que seja
eu tenho certeza que vocês vão perceber
que é porque a mudança só depende de
encontrar um porquê que seja maior do
que nós
[Aplausos]